another grim discovery in canada more
than 160 unmarked graves have been
located at a former school
for indigenous children in recent months
more than a thousand saturdays have been
uncovered
a reminder of a dark chapter in canada's
past
when a native peoples were forcibly
assimilated according to indigenous
rights activist lorelei williams this is
just the tip of the iceberg
of course this is devastating
there's a tremendous amount of grief in
our communities
already and there's going to be more
because there's definitely going to be
more found
you know not just here in the states as
well
these residential schools were all over
canada and all over the states
so our people are going through a lot
right now
it's so heartbreaking and i feel like
i'm coming to a point where i'm just
numb right now like i'm just
numb well since the first such graves
were discovered in may
there has been nationwide outrage
catholic churches have been attacked
several even burnt to the ground
moreover on canada day in early july
statues of
queen victoria and queen elizabeth ii
were toppled by crowds chanting
no pride in genocide canada's prime
minister has vowed to fight
discrimination and racism
it is difficult in moments like these
to fully comprehend
the decisions of the past that led to
these tragedies
and atrocities
but it is necessary to absorb them and
understand them
to be able to move forward well such
residential schools were tasked with
forcibly assimilating native children
into the predominantly white canadian
culture and they were made to abandon
their language and culture
many children became the victims of
physical even sexual abuse
more than 4 000 are known to have died
while confined to such institutions
lorelei williams again says it's wrong
to call these places schools
what's been going on right now you know
when they're calling them residential
schools
i really don't like the term schools
because
the the education wasn't they weren't
educating us there
they were trying to form us into white
people
and i have so many examples of how the
genocide is still happening to us
to this day you know the governments
have these policies set in place
that don't work with us even with the
recommendations from all these inquiries
there's so many inquiries that have
happened
none of them uh none of the
recommendations are taken seriously
or are implemented that could work with
us that could help us
um and then you know with the media
the media is slowly coming on board with
us
but you know like for missing and murder
indigenous women and girls they label us
in the media as sex workers drug addicts
runaways
um drunks you know so that doesn't help
us as well
so there's a lot of things against us
with the police not taking reports
seriously
and predators know that they could
target us
and people in general know that they
could target us
and so the genocide is still happening
here